innovation platforms are a way to bring
people with different experiences
together for common action in this case
they work together on natural resource
management and improve livelihood in
nile basin development challenge there
are three action research locations gel
to erada
for garage and
de garda in innovation platforms we try
to bring together stakeholders
we have communities represented
from each catalyst
there are university
research centers
and development agents
and also some farmers
we set up these innovation platforms to
build their own capacities we try to
minimize
the gap and that will improve their
linkage network
coordination
and we want them to learn one from each
other
after we identified the different
stakeholders we established innovation
platforms through sending them offshore
letters and they came to our first
innovation platform
we bring them about our objective in
terms of innovation platforms what we
want to achieve with them
we brought an issue of
what their roles could be
and together we have identified a term
of reference after we
did the first we came to the second
innovation platform with the objective
of identifying prioritizing
the main issues of rainwater management
or natural resource management because
the communities were not fully
represented in our innovation platform
members we decided to do some community
engagement activities we did a focus
group discussion we did a participatory
video in fogara through all these
engagement activities we try to
prioritize with communities what
real issues they have on the ground
so after we bring what they have
prioritized in each site to the
innovation platforms we present both
side by side and try to prioritize from
the communities and as well as from
experts all scientists have selected
forage intervention as an entry point to
deal with their big main issues which is
different in the three sides if you take
digka the guy is having a problem with
termites where these natural resource
managements are being damaged the forage
development was introduced because there
are some forage species that
resists also thermite infestation and in
gel 2 we have land degradation the
island is really degraded and the soil
productivity is very less if we
introduce these forage developments that
will complement the current
national campaign of soil and water
conservation so with that we can improve
something on land degradation
if you ask me about the fogarakis the
big issue is free grazing land is
degraded they are running out of forage
so that is direct implication in terms
of our intervention
on each innovation platform meetings we
plan together for joint action in terms
of when to plant what kinds of forage
trees we need to plant and when who is
going to do what they have also come up
with some technical groups who will
follow up in between the regular
innovation platform meetings during
planning
we try to do this action research in
small farmers and they give them an
awareness creation if they are
successful with these farmers they are
going to scale it up with other farmers
they will also promise them to
demonstrate field days if they are going
to be successful with this there are a
lot of problems that we encounter the
time that we had in nail base and
development challenge is too short
because innovation platform
is set up not only for
trying something out on the ground but
also with behavioral change when you set
platforms where there is no that kind of
experience
they can't see the impacts that
innovation platforms will bring to their
world within a short period of time
the other is also last year we face a
problem in terms of training and
participatory approach so we provide
trainings for innovation platform
members on innovation platform
facilitation skills and on participatory
research methods this year we devolve
the roles and responsibilities to our
local partners they are managing the
innovation platform meetings in a way
that we can give them a good training
come up with a good lesson in one
specific site with one issue so that we
can scale it up to other sites
you